all right I've got a huge announcement
but before I get to it I want to give
you guys a quick look into my life and
career thus far I was born in June of
1976 I played extensively with GI Joe
and transformers in the 1980s and then
moved on to Nintendo and Sega in the
1990s
I studied politics in college did
stand-up comedy in New York for 12 years
and got my dog in 2005 I had a show on
Sirius XM for a while then jumped into
the YouTube world on a couple networks
and launched this version of the Rubin
report in September of 2015 the week
after I got married as soon as we film
the first episode of the new Rubin
report my life and career changed
forever that conversation with Sam
Harris was just the beginning of the
journey yet my evolution had been
building up in me for a long time
from the very first interview I've
devoted this show to being an honest
discussion about big ideas
critical thinking and avoiding echo
chamber mentality that plagued so many
mainstream and online talk shows
literally every single week I feel that
I've learned something from a guest and
I try to incorporate that into the next
show I've evolved personally and
professionally more in the last 10
months than at any other time in my life
what we've done here and I say we
because we've done it together is sift
through static to have real
conversations about actual important
issues I don't yell at my guests or try
to prove them right at every turn I have
my own ideas challenged every day and
through listening to people I've
sharpened my worldview more than ever
before the best part is that so many of
you were having the exact same thoughts
that I was all along the way you're as
tired with the endless cries of racism
bigotry homophobia and sexism designed
to shut down productive conversation as
much as I was you guys saw liberalism
slipping away just as I did you help me
fight a battle of ideas against the
regressive left that has become
something much bigger than this show the
letters that I get from all over the
world show that these ideas
the concepts of free speech and free
thought and the exchange of ideas
transcend color nationality or sexuality
there's been an awakening here but we're
barely at the beginning after a couple
weeks of deep soul-searching I've
decided to make a major career in life
decision about my future as of right now
this very second that I'm saying these
words that are coming out of my mouth
right now we are officially
independently producing the Reuben
report I've started my own production
company and my two producers and I have
all resigned from Ora TV we're giving up
our salaries and our stable jobs and are
going all-in
to make the Reuben report bigger and
better than ever with the promise of
something amazing down the road before
anyone freaks out no we are not being
fired from aura TV I am taping this
right now at our aura studio I have
literally never had one argument with
any executive at aura about politics the
direction of the show or the type of
content that we wanted to create as I've
said many times before all they've ever
wanted me to do is make the show that I
wanted to make and that's exactly what
we did and for the absolute permanent
all-time record I am awed and beyond
humbled that Larry King the true king of
talk chose me as someone who could
possibly maybe kinda sort of fill his
suspenders well I've learned many
professional tips from Larry the real
lesson I'll always take with me from him
is to never stop being curious about
life we're making this move for many
reasons first as I've seen the show grow
I've also seen the media landscape
change immensely aura has been making
some changes and YouTube basically isn't
going to be part of their future that's
a totally fair and legit move on their
part and I have a feeling that we'll be
able to work together on various
projects in the future for me though
it's become incredibly important not
only to stay here on YouTube but
actually to double down on it I'm beyond
proud of the community that we've built
here I mean if you just take a look at
the comment section of any of our videos
they're blowing up with real
conversation most channels are just
littered with trolls and endless hateful
nonsense I would guess that 90% of the
comments we get are about the
discussions whether you agree or
disagree we've built something
absolutely amazing here and truly you
are all as much a part of it as I am
beyond just YouTube though we've got a
ton of plans on how we can grow this
show amplify its message and spread the
ideas of debate and critical thinking
but here's where I need you guys to step
up your game too as of today the Rubin
report will be 100% fan funded it hit me
that the only way I could continue to do
this show exactly how I wanted to with
full control of the message and the
distribution was only if we were only
beholden to you the audience now you can
all be in on the message of the Rubin
report not only by watching tweeting and
sharing but by actually helping us build
our studio and our future we've got a
company to build and you guys can be in
on the ground floor we'll be investing
in cameras lighting studio equipment
computers and more with our new studio
we'll be able to shoot more shows give
you more content and much much more
maybe we'll take the show on the road
maybe we'll do episodes with a live
audience maybe we'll go overseas the
opportunities are as endless as you guys
will help make them you'll also be
helping me keep my incredible team
together and feed my dog twice a day we
never wanted to put our content behind a
paywall
so we've got two ways for you to help
support the future of the Rubin report
one option is patreon where you can
choose how much to give per month and
depending on what you give we'll decide
what you get we've got shirts mugs group
video chats one-on-one video chat with
me and more patreon really will be the
lifeblood of what we're doing it'll be
the monthly budget that allows me to pay
my employees fund our new studio and
create a production company that not
only relaunches the Rubin Report but
other shows down the line the other
option is one-time donation this is if
you want to just help us kickstart this
operation in a big way right this very
second we've got some awesome tears
surprises there too from longer video
chats to getting a fish named after you
in the official Rubin report aquarium to
sponsoring your own episode of the Rubin
report it took us about two and a half
years to get to a hundred thousand
subscribers here and we got
another hundred ten and basically the
last five months if half of you can't
give anything that leaves us with a
hundred thousand who can if half of that
hundred thousand don't really like me
that leaves us with fifty thousand of
you who do if half of those people would
rather spend their money on vintage
pokemon cards that leaves us with twenty
five thousand of you and if those people
all give a couple bucks a month we could
have a budget of a hundred thousand
dollars a month just like that our
ability to do the show at a level you
can't imagine could possibly happen
overnight maybe a few of you will give a
big amount maybe some of you will give
small sums whatever it is I will be
hugely appreciative and you'll know that
by helping us you're helping the same
ideas that you care about so much so
that's it
the future of the Rubin report is right
now and it's playing out for you all to
see and be part of I hope you'll join me
as we continue to find the space that
unites us instead of divides us and
creates common ground so that we can
change the world together